it's over for trump i know that's bad
news to start at election day but i
don't want to sugarcoat it
we have been consulting the experts here
at the daily wire
we have been talking to all the great
prognosticators and
there's just no way that trump can win
because mercury is in retrograde or
something like that
i still stand by thinking that joe biden
will win but that there will also be an
unprecedented change to the nature of
rulership
in our presidency let me explain biden
is having eclipses in his first house
seventh house axis
this has happened to every presidential
winner going as far back as i've
researched literally like trump of 2016
uh clinton carter like it goes back the
eclipses are supercharged indicators
first house of self it's super charging
identity forward and this is happening
to senator harris too
there are other things that affirm this
but this is a big indicator along with
senator harris entering the literal
biggest peak period of her entire life
which is not only a peak but like
a very very impressive one for any human
being alongside that the jupiter saturn
conjunction is happening on december
21st
into 2020. they meet every 20 years and
now it's a 200 year cycle in air signs
historically coincides with transitions
of power in a very dramatic way
think caliphate the kyoto period etc but
it's close to revolutionary pluto
it looks like a literal new reality for
the us a literal new reality for the us
so obviously we can't keep our old
president in the new reality
that is what all social scientists sound
like to me
and i'm just following the science i'm
just following the data so we had a good
run
good four years it's been a good run
since 1776
but now i guess we're just in a new
reality i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowlts show
[Music]
welcome back and happy election day i
hope
i hope that that witch is wrong she is a
witch right she's consulting
astrology and i don't know i don't know
the technical term i don't know the
scientific jargon
my favorite comment from yesterday from
chosen bard
by the left's logic would waving a gay
pride flag on a
gay pride parade also be like isis this
is a great question i wondered because
yesterday
they said that that anyone waving a flag
you know so trump supporters waving the
american flag
it's just like isis waving the
isis flag so is it true of any flag but
i think
the difference might be the trucks you
know isis had kind of a little bit older
not so nice
but there was still trucks and then the
trump supporters obviously have these
giant trucks you know huge raptors and
things like that
the gay pride flag though usually is
being waived in like
really nice like teslas so i'm not i
don't know maybe that would change it
but probably i mean i'm sure i'm sure
the left would call gay pride flags
isis flags if they were being waved by
trump supporters which they often
are it's a very complicated issue
and tensions are going to be running
high all day
probably we're going to need to chill it
back tune it back a little bit try to
relax great way to do that by the way is
with a glass of wine
you know how much i love first leaf it
is a wine club that sends personalized
selections of wine
from top vineyards around the world
directly to you
the only thing better than one fantastic
bottle of wine what is it it's a case of
award-winning wine that shows up at your
doorstep
i was super skeptical of these guys when
they came on the show because
a lot of wine clubs just aren't that
good and then i tried it i ordered i got
my little
sampler package and i tried the wine and
i said wow this is actually very good
wine and i really like this and i really
like this and i really like this but i
don't really like this
so i go on and i rate them on the
website and then the more you
rate them the better that first leaf
understands your palette so they start
sending you even more
tailored shipments this stuff is
fabulous it is incredibly good wine the
price
is extraordinarily low you're not going
to beat it anywhere
and the best thing is their experts are
the ones period to your taste
subscriptions are flexible
they arrive on your schedule with
practically zero
effort what are you waiting for get that
friday feeling like i do any day
with first leaf join today you will get
six bottles of wine for 29.95 that is
outrageous
and free shipping go to tryfirstleaf.com
knowles that is six bottles of wine
for 29.95 go to try first leaf dot com
slash knowles
so everyone's making fun of this woman
on the internet for talking about how
mercury and retrograde and the eclipse
and that's why trump is going to lose
there is nothing more frivolous about
that than there is about
social science generally and all the
pollsters and everyone talking
you know we're all trying to pretend
that the people who predict
the future using i don't know charts or
something
are somehow uh less silly than the
people who try to predict the future
looking at the stars okay
social science is unfalsifiable
right so you always would hear this the
polls were right in 2016. the polls were
right in 2016
because the polls are always right the
polls are always right
if the polls are wrong like for instance
the polls say trump is going to lose in
2016 and then he wins they say well no
the polls were really right because it
was kind of close here and it was kind
of close here
and look if if the polls just say that
let's say he's got a 90
chance of losing well then if he wins
then the 10
was right so see we're right science
hashtag science hashtag data
this social scientific world polling and
everything attached to it
is part of the same progressive
apparatus as the mainstream media
as the modern university as big
technologies all of these things
and we know that the mainstream media
are fake news we know that the
universities
teach fake education we know their fake
scholarship
we know that big technology suppresses
certain stories that they don't like
like the hunter biden story from the new
york post
we know all of this and yet for some
reason we still believe the social
scientists
because they have science in their name
and even conservatives are conditioned
to love the word science and to follow
science and to pretend that there are no
biases here
the models are only as good as the data
that go into them this is the one thing
dr fauci got right
about the entire coronavirus fiasco
which is that
the models take whatever you put in
and then churn out results but you gotta
you have to have correct information
going into the models
do we have correct information going
into the models i don't know we've been
told that the polls are oversampling
democrats
the polls did get many things wrong in
2016.
so i don't know you're not allowed to
that's the one thing you're not allowed
to say in modernity i don't know
but that's what we have to acknowledge
when we look at social science
it is the most science sounding thing so
people believe it's objective
do you know do you know which poll
of presidential candidates has a better
record than
even nate silver 538 certainly than
new york times or washington post or cnn
or any of these top
outlets with the best pollsters do you
know what has a better record than all
of them combined
cookies a bakery in pennsylvania
that sells cookies with each candidate's
name and then they decide based on which
candidates
cookie sells the best who's going to win
the election the cookie
poll is more accurate than nate silver
and yet for some reason we all listen to
nate silver a pennsylvania bakery
this bakery is owned by or the bakery
rather is called
lochelle bakery owned by kathleen
lochelle
has been has predicted the last three
presidential elections correctly
this year the trump cookies are
outselling the biden cookies
six to one this is good news i know
you've all been listening to cnn polls
and nate silver polls so you're a little
bit down right now but i've got the
cookie poll for you
and the cookie poll says trump is going
to win
although i don't i do care what happens
in tonight's presidential election but
that is actually not the point i'm
making
the point i'm making what i would like
to convey to you
is that you should put much much less
uh effort and time into reading all of
those polls that everyone's trying to
get you to read
the cookies are legitimately a better
predictor
than the world's most famous
statistician
i i got i got in trouble on this show
maybe a month or two ago
because i said that statistics are a
liberal psyop
and i don't know maybe it's because i
used that kind of lurid language
people got upset about it statistics
relatively new uh category of
scholarship
it developed with the modern progressive
state it comes from the german word
statistic
and the italian word statista and it
means literally
relating to the state so as the modern
progressive administrative state
develops you get statistics which are
the data that feed into that state
that's how the universities play such an
important role in the shaping
of our modern progressive state is
because they feed the statistics
that the experts who are the bureaucrats
and the administrators of the state can
then use
to warp public policy all without any
kind of democratic input whatsoever
all without any of the kind of
traditional politics where we persuade
our fellow citizens
the difference between social science
and reading tea leaves is one of
perspective
social science assumes a material world
reading tea leaves and horoscopes and
crystal balls and whatever else you want
to look at
assumes a spiritual world neither of
those things
will actually give you the power to
predict the future
certainly not over the long run and the
world is obviously
spiritual so this is my other beyond the
cookie pole this is my other
favorite piece of social science that
that
because of the spiritual humor of the
world tells us something
karen's support biden dicks support
trump
i'm not using any slurs i'm not using
any kind of foul language
that is a scientific fact karen's
women named karen tend to support joe
biden
and men named richard tend to support
donald trump
the new york times has been conducting
polls with siena college for two months
now
to look it out people with certain names
vote
so if you if you look here you've got
the the most common
name the most likely popular name to
support biden
all the way down there is karen
michael is up up toward the trump line
of things michaels tend to support trump
and then richard dick most likely
popular name to support donald trump now
you can look a little
more closely at this and find out that
there are a few women who are more
likely to support
trump than biden linda jennifer
nancy those are women who will are more
likely to vote for trump there is one
man who's 50 50. that's joseph
and then all and christopher too also 50
50.
and then all the rest of the pro-biden
people
so so every single pro-biden name
is a woman
which i guess should make sense
tends to be the k and some women then
vote for
trump because married women tend to vote
republican and single women tend to vote
democrat
so we need we need more nancies in the
world we need more jennifers
we need more lindas is that going to
make the prediction for you is that
going to convince you that trump is
going to win
well there is an there is an actual
expert and i don't mean an expert
who wears a lab coat and he's a social
scientist and he's he pours over
spreadsheets all day i mean an
actual expert with actual experience in
politics
one of the best political analysts in
the country
he is predicting a trump win which would
probably make us all
feel safer you know what else makes us
feel safer ring ring home security
there's
a thousand reasons why protecting your
home matters to you
you want to know who dropped off that
package you want to know if your
mother-in-law is going to come visit you
want to know if roving marauders are
going to be torching your neighborhood
you can see who they are in the camera
either way whatever it is whether you're
in your home whether you're at the
office whether you're
at that back by the pool maybe you're on
vacation you can check in
on your home from anywhere with one
simple app with ring you
can keep an eye on your home no matter
where you are right from your phone
if anybody comes by you will have that
peace of mind
anytime knowing that your home is
protected
i am going to be getting the heck out of
dodge after this election and i'm going
to be moving to tennessee and i'm going
to have a nice house
because you can't it's hard to get nice
houses in l.a but you can in tennessee
and i am so excited to install that ring
right on there
so that i can tell when the marauders
and the in-laws are coming into town
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kid at ring.com
slash knowles know w-l-e-s comes with
rings video doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience plus
free two-day shipping go to ring.com
can wles that is ring.com
slash knowles
be on the cookies be on the horoscopes
beyond the cairns
there is a guy with experience who is
going out on a limb most politicians
prefer
to stay vague about everything so
they're always right
this guy always just runs headfirst into
the burning building newt gingrich
former speaker of the house former
presidential candidate
all around great political analyst
he is coming out and predicting
that trump is going to win and he's
going to tell you exactly where and how
he's going to win
i think trump wins with
324 electoral votes
i think that uh the um
leftist will be in total shock by the
end of the evening
trump will get a much larger share of
the black vote than any republican
since 1960 he will
do surprisingly well with latinos he
will have an enormous
almost unimaginable turnout
in rural and small town america
i was just being told a while ago about
a trump
rally in arizona that had
96 miles of cars with trump flags
96 miles that's a level of enthusiasm
you watch two or three uh biden
events and then you watch two or three
trump events
you can't have any doubt about where the
weight of enthusiasm is and obviously
none of us would have that doubt either
i mentioned i think yesterday on the
show i went to vote in los angeles
and i had a maga hat on and i was a
little nervous you know because
we could be shot you know or in a very
liberal precinct
and someone did yell at me and he yelled
at me
to tell me how excited he was for trump
to win and he liked the daily wire and
he was
he was obviously a conservative guy
another guy next to him yells at me
and he was yelling at me to not put my
ballot in the place where the liberals
were gonna
steal him but to put it in the safer
place he was obviously a conservative
too
plus me plus my wife so you got four
conservative people all happen to be in
line at the same time
at a very very liberal precinct in la
that's strange
doesn't mean i'm predicting la is going
to go for trump doesn't mean i'm
predicting greenland would go for trump
even though that would be
the most absolutely delicious thing that
could happen
in political reality you know
on earth right now that would be just so
great heads would explode if
if california went conservative i'm not
saying that's going to happen
i am saying there is a big big
enthusiasm gap now it may well be the
case
that sure nobody likes joe biden but
there
just are enough democrats and the
democrats are motivated enough to vote
even though they don't like the guy even
though kamala harris
is also awful that they're they're just
in the numbers they've got it
that's that's what some of the polls are
reflecting but gingrich has experience
an experience is a kind of expertise
that is i think much better than some
guy who
studied statistics or something for too
long now
i love listening to predictions from
people with that kind of experience i
hate listening to predictions
from people who are actually involved in
counting the votes
because this election very likely could
come down to pennsylvania it could come
down to one state pennsylvania
and the attorney general in pennsylvania
guy named josh shapiro
is already calling the election for joe
biden
i don't know if ben is related to josh
they do share a last name if he is i
would urge ben
to call cousin josh and say josh stop
being such a jerk
because josh shapiro who is he's not
a campaign operative there he is the
attorney general of the state
he says quote if all the votes are added
up in pa
trump is going to lose that's why he's
working overtime to subtract as many
votes as possible from this process
for the record he's owen 6 against us in
court we've protected voting rights now
ignore the noise vote
highly inappropriate stuff highly
inappropriate for someone who's the
attorney general this is supposed to be
a fairly by the books judicious
position to be so
nakedly partisan and to say that
they're going to keep counting these
votes until they get the answer that
they want
which is what he's saying isn't he part
of these court fights that that have
been going on in pennsylvania
regards when to when to stop counting
votes
because we we now have universal
unsolicited mail-in ballots we've never
had that sort of thing before in the
history of the united states
there are elections there was an
election day for a reason then we made
it in election week and then alexa
election month but now even ballots that
are
are mailed after after the due date
are going to be counted in the election
how does that work
are you going to keep mailing ballots
until the end of november are you going
to keep mailing them in december how
about next march
if you don't like something trump did
can you mail in some ballots then no we
have
deadlines for a reason and if you don't
get your ballot in by the deadline just
like if you didn't show up on election
day
that's it sorry buster your vote doesn't
count except
unfortunately the courts have sided with
the liberals here because of people like
john roberts that turncoat chief justice
of the supreme court
who was nominated by a republican now
he's a liberal which is why it's
important to have
actual strong conservative presidents
who have hutzpah to nominate actual
strong conservative judges
unlike weaker republican presidents in
the past
now the one thing i do love about this
tweet from josh shapiro is
this is going to be great grounds to
challenge whatever corruption
crooked practices they have while they
dig up a bunch of fraudulent votes in
pennsylvania
if if the democrats try to steal the
election this is going to come in real
handy
because it's basically the attorney
general of pennsylvania saying hey i'm
committing election fraud
don't forget to vote okay can't wait to
bring that one to court
that is lawlessness how does the left
justify this stuff
the left justifies this by saying that
president trump is as bad as hitler
and actually there's one prominent
leftist
who just said that president trump is
worse
than hitler that is the kind of person
this is an expert
this this person is an expert who said
this a doctor medical doctor
and she could say something so stupid
and me i'm not an expert
i don't even know how to fix a car and i
would never say something so stupid
but you know when i am trying to fix a
car rockauto.com comes in very handy
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store
and someone demanding quick answers to
things like is your odyssey an
l x or an e x i don't know what letter
comes before the x
just give me the part but they never
have the part anyway so what they do is
they go into the back then they go
online they probably go to rockauto.com
they order the part and then they charge
you twice as much don't do that skip the
line skip the hassle
you can go to rockauto.com they've
always got this great catalog
to see all the parts available for your
car or truck the catalog is so easy to
navigate that even i
can do it and the prices on rockauto.com
are always reliably low they are the
same for professionals
and do-it-yourselfers and then whatever
i am i'm neither a professional nor a
do-it-yourselfer
i'm like some third lesser category of
guys who have cars
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
super easy
you can you can check it out at a glance
great selection reliably low prices head
on over there
right now rockauto.com and then write
knowles in their how did you hear about
us box
so that they know that we sent you that
is rockauto.com check out all the parts
available
for your car or truck and then write
knowles in the how did you hear about us
box this woman dr bandy x
lee is the president of the world mental
health coalition
how ironic and a frequent guest on cnn
and msnbc
much less ironic and she is saying not
only is donald trump similar to hitler
he's actually worse
donald trump is not an adolf hitler at
least hitler improved the daily life of
his followers
had discipline and required more of
himself to gain
the respect of his followers even with
the same pathology
there are varying degrees of competence
so i i i guess i see the joke that she's
trying to make first of all just as a
general rule
it's probably not good in mainstream
public life to make
jokes about hitler for millions and
millions of people if you're a
if you're a public health expert if
you're sort of a mainstream analyst
it's not it's just not a good idea but i
get the joke she's trying to make she's
saying oh gosh you think hitler's
bad and you're comparing trump trump's
even worse than hitler because at least
hitler
was disciplined or something like that
but then she goes on she's so effusive
in her praise of hitler that you start
to think hold on
does this lady ever this is going beyond
the joke now you're kind of talking
and yeah and at least hitler had those
beautiful
wonderful blue eyes that you would just
get lost and all that you say hold on
calm down bandy come that's you've taken
this way
way too far also she's wrong about
hitler
is the other thing because people don't
know anything about history hitler
let me check the list did not improve
the daily life of his followers
he did not have much discipline right
wasn't he a drug addict wasn't he
kind of he'd lose his temper all the
time and he's a he
committed suicide not very disciplined
uh he required more of himself to gain
the respect of his followers i don't i
don't know that that's
i don't even know what that means but if
it means anything i don't think it's
true
so no i don't think trump is hitler i
don't think trump is worse than hitler i
think trump is
a much better fella than hitler but
they believe this stuff i mean this is
not just a joke that she's trying to
make
she is expressing a view that many
people think i mean i have
friends and family who are liberals who
tell me that the trump is a nazi you
know and
it's the implication is the trump
supporters are nazis which is more than
a little bit offensive
they blame him for everything the
atlantic writer anne applebaum
just just tweeted out some some truly
varsity level gas lighting
if you're in a major metropolitan area
right now you might notice
that buildings are boarded up if you go
if i go to beverly hills right now
rodeo drive most famous road in in
beverly hills one of the most famous
roads in the world
is boarded up stores have taken their
merchandise
put it into warehouses because they're
afraid of riots
and looting the kind of rides and
looting that we've seen for the past
seven or eight months
do you know who anne applebaum at the
atlantic blames she blames trump
when conservatives celebrated trump's
election four years ago did they know
that in 2020 we would board up shops
prepare for riots and the arrival of
militias
game out ways he might steal the
election protest aggressive voter
suppression
this is what he's done to america hold
on hold on
does anybody really believe that the
riots and looting
that people are preparing for tonight
would come from conservatives
no not even anne applebaum believes that
nobody believes that
wild gangs of of trump supporters are
going to go steal gucci handbags on
rodeo drive
nobody believes that it's going to be
leftists it's going to be
biden supporters it's going to be the
same biden supporters that have been
looting and rioting and burning down the
country
for the past seven months not one of
them not one of the people who stole a
gucci handbag
is supporting donald trump all of them
if they have a preference at all among
candidates
are supporting joe biden so how's that
trump's fault well because
he might steal the election he might
steal the election hillary clinton said
that joe biden shouldn't concede under
any circumstances democrats are openly
aggressively trying to steal the
election
the attorney general in pennsylvania is
calling the state for joe biden
before the votes have been cast before
election day
there there trump is going to steal the
election the democrats
refused to concede the 2016 election up
to today
up to today on election night 2016
hillary clinton would not come out and
concede
she sent john podesta out there to very
limply
say thanks for showing up hillary's
always been here for you
except now when she's supposed to be
here the most so we're not going to
concede and then later she had to sort
of concede but she hasn't really
she said it was an illegitimate election
that was stolen from her and then the
bureaucracy
in collusion with the democratic
national committee and the hillary
clinton campaign
tried to overturn the trump election for
three and a half years
republicans are trying to steal the
election and voter suppression what
voter suppression
how show me how donald trump
is trying to perpetrate voter
suppression well he
he he only wants citizens to vote yeah
right that's called
following the law well he thinks that
you shouldn't be able to vote you know
after election day
right yeah you shouldn't that's called
following the law
can i vote look listen maybe i didn't i
don't like how the 2008 election turned
out can i vote now
am i allowed to vote maybe maybe i
didn't cast my ballot in 2008 maybe i
want to vote now
because i i and i want my vote to be
heard can i vote can i undo the obama
presidency why not why can't i deadlines
don't matter election day doesn't matter
why are democrats trying to suppress the
vote everything this woman said is
just not true
they are the ones burning down the
country and this
to me is the choice on election day
trump supporters wave the american flag
biden supporters burn the american flag
that's the choice that's the choice
michael not all biden supporters are
burning the american flag
right i'm not saying all biden
supporters burn the american flag
but all the people burning the american
flag are biden supporters
well maybe some trump supporter no no
trump supporter has ever burned the
american flag not once
not one time in fact trump supporters
treat the american flag with great
respect
i remember i forget if it was hillary or
obama during one of their campaigns
some stupid staffer took a photo at an
election setup and the photo
was a a flag it was black and white was
a flag kind of on the ground
and they were getting ready to hang it
up and this caused
a an unexpected controversy that the
democrats didn't understand why it was
controversial
because the democrats don't realize that
you're not supposed to let the flag
touch the ground
patriots people who respect our country
and respect the symbols of our country
know that we were raised to know that
whenever if i was at a fourth of july
parade or something the flag touched the
ground my mother would say michael you
can't the flag can never touch the
ground
never many people in this country
don't know that anymore and when you
have no respect for the symbol
you have no respect for the symbolized
that is what symbols do right symbols
represent things
if you disrespect what is being if you
disrespect what is representing the
thing you are disrespecting the thing
itself
and now more i mean i think we know this
intuitively why else would people burn
the flag it's just a piece of cloth
right
no it's a symbol of the country why else
protest the flag like at nfl games or or
at democratic caucus meetings why
protest the flag
because it's a piece of cloth no it's
because it's a symbol of the thing
itself and the left doesn't like this
country
and they've been engaged in a more than
century-long campaign
to undermine this country because they
believe it's rotten from the beginning
they believe the founding was not in
1776
or 1620 when the mayflower arrived thing
was 1619 when the
slaves got here that this country is
defined by every rotten thing it's ever
done
and none of the good things and that all
of our country's enemies are defined by
only the good things they've ever done
and none of the rotten things
and if they can't find enough rotten
things to accuse america of committing
they'll make them up that's what they're
doing
oh the past was bad now we've got to
move into the future and the future's
going to be so much better
we're we're the ones we've been waiting
for thank goodness we're here to
liberate us from that awful oppressive
past
of america that gave us our lives those
awful forefathers who gave us
everything we have in this country every
political institution
those awful rotten people that's the
election do you like the country do you
not like the country if you like the
country vote for trump if you don't like
the country
vote for biden and be on the side of the
people burning
burning it down which makes sense i
guess and lighting the flag on fire
and destroying stores and assaulting
people in the street
those are the choices but michael
trump's a or biden rather is a sort of
moderate guy he's he's not a radical
i don't know maybe he is maybe he is i
don't think he believes anything at all
i think he's a complete empty suit
and i think he's got an empty head but
what i do know is he has sided with the
people
who are attacking this country and who
are lighting the flags on fire and so
i'm not on his side
i'm on trump's side it's amazing the
the degree to which anti-americanism has
has
affected our country so much so that
full professional sports teams are now
pretending that this isn't even
the american country at all which we'll
get to in one second but you understand
how important this election is so tune
in tonight to our live stream
at 3 p.m eastern 12 p.m pacific it's not
even tonight that's in the middle of the
day
featuring special guests live interviews
and more we will be covering the results
with you in real time
even better join daily wire now and get
25 off with code election so you can
watch all of our election coverage live
on our apple tv or roku app watch the
election with us
at dailywire.com get 25 off your daily
wire membership
with code election when you sign up
today we will be right back with a lot
more
many people don't believe that this even
is our country
and this is not just some radical left
idea that you learn
in some critical studies class in
college
this is being pushed by major sports
teams
so the chicago blackhawks now before any
of their
matches i don't even know whether games
matches i don't know
they read this statement this is a
statement that they will now read before
every single one of these games
the chicago blackhawks acknowledge that
the team
its foundation and the spaces we
maintain work and compete within
stand upon the traditional homelands of
the miami
sauk fox ho chunk menominee
and the council of the three fires the
ojibwe
odawa and potawatomi nations
we understand that this land holds
immense significance for its original
stewards
the native nations and the peoples of
this region we would also like to
recognize that our team's namesake
sock war leader blackhawk serves as a
continuous reminder
of our responsibility to the native
american communities we live amongst
and draw inspiration from
what what
the first of all the original
inhabitants of this land
what is it what is an original
inhabitant of this land
is it is it the tribe is it the
sub-tribes the tribes within the tribes
is it the tribes that conquer the other
tribes if i go down to the southwest
united states
and i which is the united states now by
the way it's not apache land it's not
it's not comanche it's not whatever land
it's the united states it's american
land and i go down there
and all of a sudden i get some pang of
american guilt i don't know why i would
but let's say i think i'm immune to that
but let's say i did
would i then read a statement say i
acknowledge that i am standing on
comanche land i guess i could because we
did take it from the comanche
but the command she took it from the
apache so should i
who should i acknowledge in my statement
of guilt
the comanche or the apache probably none
of them who are we which which tribe are
we ignore i guess they're going to
acknowledge all of the tribes because
every tribe and every other people and
every other place and every other
country
on the face of the earth from the
beginning of civilization to the present
has been so much better than us we've
committed all these crimes i don't think
so
the the crime that they're accusing the
united states of committing is the crime
of conquest
which in some instances is true in some
instances isn't true in some instances
we had treaties that we
upheld in some instances we had treaties
we didn't uphold in some places we just
won territory throughout right war
but you know what i do know about the
war the law of conquest
every other people throughout all of
human history has exercised it as well
why uniquely is the united states to
feel sorry for this
to apologize to rend our garments and
nash our teeth
the reason is because we're the most
advanced country in the history of the
world
advanced in many ways too i'm not saying
we're this absolutely perfect virtuous
country we kill a million babies a year
we're advanced
in in barbarism as well but we are
advanced we are much more advanced
and sophisticated in in
any broad sense of that term country
than than anyone else
and we feel bad about that so we have to
pretend that we're not and we have to
pretend it was all
ill-gotten gains but it wasn't it wasn't
part of the reason
why our civilization has been able to
advance so much
and by the way to be really nice to
everyone else in the world and let
people come in by in
at a higher rate than anyone else ever
on earth the largest mass migration of
human beings has occurred
over the past 60 years ever in recorded
history
and it's occurred into the united states
because of how generous we are in
immigration
so the united states has been able to
achieve that that degree of prominence
because of a specific culture and a
specific civilization specific ideas and
specific people
that now the flag burners want to
tear down they want to overturn them
and that will not make the world better
off for everybody else that will plunge
us all
into even greater barbarism so what map
are we looking at tonight
who's going to win trump or the flag
burners who's going to win
my map and you know me i don't i don't
consult the horoscope
i don't uh have a cookie shop i but
i did make my prediction so my map is uh
all
it's going to be all red and plus
greenland
so greenland also red so a lot of people
talking about 538 538
electoral votes that's him i'm going to
say 623 because i'm going to give
greenland to 85 electoral votes why
i don't know why not it's a big big
landmass i don't know how many people
are there but that's fine seems big
that's what i want and i'm i'm only half
joking i'm only i
don't i don't think the whole entire uh
country is going to vote for trump
but i i don't know what's going to
happen
if if i wake up tomorrow well i guess
i'll still be on set tonight
if i find out tonight that joe biden won
narrowly
wouldn't be surprised if i find trump
won narrowly wouldn't be surprised if i
find out that
biden won in a big way you know he got a
huge
number of electoral votes i guess i
wouldn't be that surprised it would that
would surprise me a little bit more
and if i found out trump won 40 states
or some some crazy you know some insane
number like that
i also wouldn't be that surprised i
don't know the
the models are only as good as the data
you put in and we're in such a bizarre
year with the unprecedented widespread
unsolicited male invalids
with the coronavirus lockdowns i guess
coronavirus is not unprecedented we've
had epidemics like this and actually
much worse than this before
but the lockdowns the politicization of
the coronavirus by
the left mostly is unprecedented
the degree of fraud that you've seen and
i'm not talking about fraud even at the
polling places although
attorney general shapiro should make us
a little worried about that in
pennsylvania
but i'm talking about the fraud in the
bureaucracy itself
this is the first coup d'etat in my
lifetime what happened in 2016 to the
present
is the first attempted coup in my
lifetime
there have been others in the united
states but first one since i've been
alive
so i don't know how to factor that into
my calculations
there is a strange phenomenon going on
which is these
organic trump parades you know because
there haven't been quite as many rallies
i think trump's done something like
12 rallies in the last few days i mean
he's he's just absolutely killing it in
the last few days on the campaign trail
but because there haven't been as many
rallies and formal events as there have
been in years past
people are just creating their own trump
parades
i've seen them in california i've seen
them all over the place people get in
their cars through the trucks and they
have an american flag and they have a
trump flag and
maybe a gadsden flag something like that
and they go down and they go on for
miles and miles and miles
you don't see that you haven't seen that
but you don't see any biden parades
there are no but not one
time has there been a biden parade
that is that shows you that something is
going on in the country i suspect
that enthusiasm difference is going to
factor into the
election results even if it doesn't low
and let's say that there isn't fraud for
a second
that still tells you something about our
politics because you've got a country
that is so starkly divided and not just
about this issue or that issue
not just about taxes not just about
certain rates of immigration
not not even about really serious issues
like abortion
but about the country itself some people
like the country
want more of it have loyalty to their
country love it
and and other people don't love it they
hate it they hate it
they want to fundamentally transform it
i'm not saying this even as
like a cheap political shot i'm saying
if you ask them they'd say yeah i hate
this country
i love what this country what they would
usually say is this no i love our
country
i hate what we were but i love what we
could be i hate what we are now but i
love
what we could be if we only live up to
the ideals that i
i invented five seconds ago not that
george washington or thomas jefferson
invented but that i invented
sure if you if you hate what a country
is now and you hate what a country was
in the past
and you enjoy what you think the country
could be in the future because you've
got a crystal ball
that means you hate your country you
like your daydreams
and you hate your country
and that is a that's a fundamental
distinction chesterton famously said
that there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped
that there are there are principles that
we have to take on faith there are
axioms that we need to begin with
in this country in any country and one
of them is you have to love your country
you have to have patriotism you have to
support it you have to not try to
destroy it you don't have to not try not
to subvert it
and and we're having a disagreement over
that question right now
so even let's say biden wins fair and
square
hope doesn't happen let's say it does
that puts us in a very
very bad position you've seen the riots
you've seen
the mayhem from the from the military
wing of the democratic party known as
antifa or blm
just just the other day they were the
cops were getting ready for the for the
election
unrest listen to the sort of things that
these
leftist activists scream at cops i hope
all of your children get raped
that's that's who we're dealing with
folks no that's just the extreme that's
just one person
it's not just one person it's not just
one person and it's not just going on in
new york
they've torched new york they've torched
dc they've torched chicago
they've torched la they've torched all
over this country
atlanta they've all over kenosha i don't
i can name
however many more towns this is a
national problem and an ideological
problem and a political party problem
because all of these people are aligning
with the democratic party and not one of
them is aligning with the republican
party
and and the way that we deal with these
cultural problems is not to throw our
hands up in the air and say well
okay i guess we've got to just do better
at persuading our citizens now the time
to persuade is now
and the way that we do that is in
politics the way that we deal with these
political questions is in politics
all too often conservatives have tried
to make this neat distinction between
culture and politics and there's
something to be said for that because
the movies i guess are different
than how we vote the mainstream media is
kind of in the middle there right
but there's no neat distinction here
politics is not just some tiny little
thing that we should
we should surrender power on politics is
how we live together as people and how
we persuade one another
and how we can govern ourselves comes
from the the greek
polis the city-states how citizens come
together
politics is a much broader realm than i
think many conservatives have been
willing to admit
and today is the day that we express our
views on that
stakes could not be higher that is why
the great taylor swift
our hero is coming out to sing
our country back into a democrat malaise
why are so many powerful people trying
to make it so
difficult for us to vote it keeps the
look on your face the moment you heard
the news
you're screaming inside and frozen
inside you did all
in his big things plan their hands are
stained with bread
oh how quickly they forget
they aren't gonna help us
[Music]
[Music]
obviously none of that is true she opens
up with the kamala harris clip why are
so many people trying to make it so hard
to vote it has never been easier to vote
you don't need an id you probably don't
need to be an american citizen you don't
need to request an absentee ballot you
don't need to show up on election day
you can vote basically whenever
apparently after the election perhaps
or at least after the deadline to send
in your
mail-in ballot it's never ever been
easier to it's much too easy to vote
right now
because the the system itself is open to
such fraud
and the men these men are just enriching
themselves they're enriching them
donald trump doesn't take a salary he's
lost a billion dollars in office
helping the country none of that is true
none of that is true i hope it's just
desperation
from our friends on the left i hope the
election goes well for us tonight
we will find out we're obviously going
to have that election coverage
in any case i would like to express a
little bit of gratitude for how fun
the past four years have been i hope it
continues for another four years i hope
we get another
a replay of election night 2016.
so i will say goodbye to you for now
until our election night later
and i will play you out on a glorious
montage
from 2016. just last week he confirmed
the national review that he is again
considering a run in 2016.
do it do it look at me
do it i will personally write you a
campaign check
now on behalf of this country which does
not want you to be president
but which badly wants you to run which
republican candidate
has the best chance of winning the
general election
of the declared ones right now donald
trump
[Applause]
president obama will go down as perhaps
the worst president
in the history of the united states
exclamation point
at real donald trump well
at real donald trump at least i will go
down
as a president
so right now we have hillary's about a
75 or an eighty percent favorite we have
different versions of forecasts
paul has hillary clinton up by double
digits nationally 12 points 50 to 38
four-way race clinton leading in florida
clinton leading in north carolina
clinton leading in ohio clinton leading
in nevada i could go on and on and on
uh i continue to believe mr trump will
not be president
[Music]
and so right now mr trump to answer your
call for political honesty i just want
to say
you're not going to be president all
right
it's been fun it's been great
i love you
[Music]
but come on come on buddy we have a
major projection right now
donald trump will take ohio that cnn
projects donald trump will carry the
state of florida
huge win for donald trump donald trump
we project will win
in kentucky within indiana with its 11
electoral votes west
virginia global tennessee mississippi
south carolina alabama north dakota
with its three electoral votes and south
dakota texas
arkansas louisiana the state of montana
of north carolina
georgia iowa utah wisconsin arizona
kansas with six electoral votes nebraska
with its five electoral votes
and wyoming with its three electoral
votes
sorry to keep you waiting complicated
business
thank you everybody we're not we are not
going to be
taking any questions thank you guys
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the andrew clavin
show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton